my life hasn't been what you probably
think it has we all have our struggles
have you ever been in love a long long
time ago you so many times yeah all the
all the time
welcome to the future
life is good but it can be better and why
shouldn't it be all you need is to want it
think about finally having everything
you always wanted
I can save  today. But you can save the world.
Steve? Diana?
now
I take what I want in return
everyone will see
the world needs you.
you know what you need to do
nothing good is born from lies
and greatness is not what you think
It's all art
oh that's just a trash can it's just a
trash can yeah yeah
Welcom back everyone, it's Charlie this is going to be my Wonder Woman 1984 trailer breakdown in Easter
eggs there's a whole bunch of stuff
going on in this they told us what's
going on with the villain Maxwell Lord
in cheetah so we'll break it all down if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the easter egg
videos we'll do a new DC merch giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your favorite
moment from the trailer on the video
make all the mandalorian Pedro Pascal
baby Yoda jokes that you want about this
well just start at the beginning of the
trailer and work our way through shot by
shot the trailer picks up in 1984 she's
been continuing to save the world save
everyone around her do as much as she
can but she's super lonely as you can
see because most of her friends from
World War one have died off there's a
whole bunch of pictures and Easter eggs
in the background like you look at the
little mantel here there's a picture of
Trevor Manor something that she coined
in the name of Steve Trevor they
actually go back to Steve Trevor's watch
a couple times remember he gave it to
her before he went so she carried it
with her but they start with it at the
beginning of the trailer then before he
appears to her again in full
members-only 80's attire with his giant
fanny pack
they go back to the watch but it's only
after you get the Maxwell Lord intro so
if you're familiar with the classic
version of Maxwell Lord that they
introduced in and around the Justice
League International period in the
comics they're doing something a little
bit different with the character you
find out that she's pretty friendly with
cheetah before she becomes cheetah this
is the Barbara Minerva version of the
character the reason why they said they
went with Kristen Wiig for this roles
because they needed someone who could do
funny and personable like this was kind
of an awkward funny person talking to
her about being lonely have you ever
been in love she says Oh a long time ago
referencing Steve Trevor she says she's
been in love a bunch of times so it's
just this funny nice conversation that
they're having over drinks and they
needed someone who could do that and
then also go to the full crazy town
full-blown cheetah makeup and they did
say that her costume would be a
combination of practical and special
effects so when she goes full cheetah
they did have to use a little bit of
visual effects to tune her up you may
have also noticed an Easter Egg in the
way that they did the titles for the
movie in the Warner Brothers logo there
inspired by the classic Christopher
Reeve Superman titles with the way that
they fly at the screen now these are
just dialed up to the maximum 80s level
with a bunch of neon thrown in but part
of the reason for setting the movie in
1984 is it's meant to be the maximum
period of our current ideology maximum
greed maximum egos in what kind of
villains would come out of that and
that's where you get the Maxwell Lord
villain in this movie the song playing
in the trailer is Blue Monday classic
80s track are you going to the mall
today obviously malls were huge in the
80s they spent most of stranger things season 3
inside a giant mall so of
course there's going to be a mall during
this if you were at Comic Con in Hall
age you probably saw some of this
footage way before everyone else it's
not clear why she has to destroy the
mall security cameras when she's saving
these people but two people just try to
shoot it up so she takes them down it's
also meant to give you a preview for the
crazy practical way that they did their
action scenes they said that very little
of this is actual special effects they
try to do as much of it real-world as
they could you get your first preview
for Maxwell Lord the way patty Jenkins
explained to him in the movie is that
he's the king of infomercials so he's
trying to sell everyone on their
fantasies so because he's a super
powerful telepath in the comics and he
has this giant radar array it wherever
he broadcasts his signal from you can
imagine that there's probably some of
his comic book telepathy involved in
what he's trying to sell people on this
specific shot of him with all these
infomercials is also meant to be an
Easter Egg for this classic 80s ad his
speech about everyone getting everything
that they want fulfilling their
fantasies having the better life that
they want is also meant to be a parody
of Ronald Reagan's famous shining city
on the hill speech during the 80s
because it's 1984 Reagan would be
President this time if you don't
remember the shining city on a hill
speech it was a big speech that he gave
to the American public to pump them up
because we were coming off this really
bad recession the economy was terrible
and he was basically coming out and
saying no everybody could have their
dreams there's this bright future ahead
for us trying to get them to forget
about all the terrible things that have
been happening for the past couple of
years so Maxwell Lord is sort of the
darkest timeline parody of that you also
notice how they've tuned the color on
her way up I mean the whole movie is
super saturated but her costume pops way
more than I've seen it in any of the
other movies that she's been in gal
gadot also claims that this movie is
bigger than any movie she's done before
which includes the Justice League movie
you get another quick shot at Barbara
Minerva thinking about things that she
wants obviously it's not totally clear
how she becomes cheetah and how close
that's going to be to her a comic book
origin but in the comics she became
cheetah when she was cursed by a village
of people she's an archaeologist in the
comics she's an archaeologist during
this you see Maxwell Lord holding this
artifact I'm assuming that she has
something to do with getting him that
artifact
love the way they introduce Steve Trevor
at this party though he walks up and
puts the watch in her hand just like he
did before he died back during World War
one it doesn't seem like she questions
it that much she just completely
embraces him like oh I'm so happy that
you're back the rest of the trailer is a
little misleading in the way that they
cut it you're just meant to assume that
he's really back but because of Maxwell
Lords powers and how he's trying to sell
everyone on this fake life I also kind
of feel like there's some fakery going
on with Steve Trevor in the movie like
maybe it is fake mine space Steve Trevor
and it's just Maxwell Lords power that
he's broadcasting this signal trying to
make everyone feel like they're getting
the things that they want when really
it's not happening what's not totally
clear is Maxwell Laura's powers in the
movie does he start out with powers or
is it this artifact that gives him
powers to make everything feel like it's
that much more real this is just another
big disaster that's happening near the
Capitol building in the street you see
you're wearing civilian clothes that
look a lot like Lynda Carter's clothes
during the 70s Wonder Woman series
there's a rumor that she'll have a cameo
somewhere in this movie but I didn't
spot her anywhere in the trailer for
some reason the White House security
guards are firing at her and Steve
Trevor it's not clear why if that has
something to do with Maxwell Lord or he
makes the security guards believe that
Wonder Woman is trying to kill the
president
great slow-mo shot they just want to
show you her abilities it's been a while
since we've seen her on screen so
they're just trying to show off how
fantastic their action scenes are and
how much more they've evolved the way
that they use her in scenes they really
upgraded the way she uses that lasso but
I think that they've just used the last
couple of movies to perfect what they
can do with the lasso practically like
how do you make the lasso look cool in
action scenes I will get to the last
winged lightning part in a second
because yes I do think that there is an
invisible jet that we just don't see
because it's invisible during the
trailer
this kind of seems like it's Barbara
Minerva after she starts to transform
into the cheetah persona like she gets
what it is that she wants or she pays
that price the first movie was Wonder
Woman just being completely amazed by
modern-day London now it's Steve Trevor
just completely being blown away by
everything in present-day 1984 you see
her intervening in an international
incident this wall being torn down I
think is meant to be a reference to the
Berlin wall being torn down but that
wasn't till 1989 so this isn't the
Berlin wall or anything like that this
is somewhere a completely different I
think it's just meant to give you a
sense in the movie for what she's doing
internationally she's busy helping
people all over the world I know there
are a lot of timeline questions because
they said in Batman V Superman they
implied that she hadn't been around for
the last forty or so years most of those
timeline inconsistency questions can be
answered by the idea that they retconned
her backstory in Batman V Superman when
they got to the first Wonder Woman movie
so when this movie picks up in 1984
she's been busy being Wonder Woman since
World War one ended here's the weird
thing about mine space Steve Trevor
though he actually punches one of these
guards so either it's Wonder Woman
imagining him doing that or it really is
happening but it's not clear if this has
something to do with the artifact that
Maxwell Lord has like maybe he is
getting people to conjure these things
up for themselves because of his
telepathic powers but maybe the artifact
has something to do with making those
things real turning fake things into
real things you have to remember that
the 80s was a very fake it till you make
it kind of decade you get a lot of
flashbacks that that mascara you see
them cut her running down the street in
Washington DC trying to save people with
her as a little girl running in
formation with the other Amazons but
here's why I think that there's an
invisible jet in the movie because she
lasso something in the middle of the air
that's not there like literally the
lasso grabs onto something and lifts her
off the ground and there's nothing there
so what else could that be but the
invisible jet but because Maxwell Lord
has that giant transmitters sattelite
I'm assuming that this device is
connected to that somehow and he's using
it to broadcast his telepathic signal to
get everybody to just believe everything
that they want to believe this big
action scene on the road seems like it's
happening in the same foreign country
where this wall is being torn down also
just another big action scene meant to
show you how crazy they can get with her
action scenes there's an
time action scene with her going up
against this giant armament then you
have a much bigger version of her
seeming like she's lassoing the
lightning bolts so like I said if there
is invisible jet during this maybe there
is an invisible jet somewhere in this
scene that we're just not seeing the
golden armor looks fantastic if you guys
aren't big comic-book readers this is
just meant to be a version of her gold
armor from the comics it just meant to
be a much more warlike version of the
costume she wears obviously the wings
are just meant to represent some of the
excess of the 80s so sort of dovetails
with the theme of the movie the
heightened state of everything so that's
why her armor levels are over 9,000 and
the reason why she would need to wear
something like this covering her arms
and her legs is when Cheeta goes full
cheetah because when she gets her powers
cheetah is strong enough to take Wonder
Woman down and her claws are strong
enough to just rip right through her
flesh so that's why Wonder Woman would
need to protect her open exposed areas
then because there's a lot of humor in
Wonder Woman movies they ended that
funny tag with Steve Trevor not being
able to tell the difference between
modern trash bins in art that's also
meant to be a joke about art during the
80s is it art or is it just a piece of
trash who knows but if you spotted any
big easter eggs in the trailer that I
didn't mention in the video just write
them below in the comments
Crisis on Infinite Earths episode 1 starts tonight my next video
will be for episode 1 so as long as you
have alerts enabled for my channel you
should get all those videos but click
here for that brand new
Crisis on Infinite Earths
trailer and click here for my
Mandalorian episode 5 video for more
Pedro Pascal thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome see you
guys tonight!